[Musica]
io vi devo confessare una cosa
Io sono stato un giocatore di pallavolo
ma non un giocatore di pallavolo diciamo
scarso è un giocatore di pallavolo
abbastanza bravo L'ho fatto per tanti
anni Forse vi chiederete Ma perché mi
stai dicendo una cosa perché qui forse
molti mi conoscono e probabilmente si
stanno facendo la domanda Come avrà
fatto
visto visto
diciamo questo io me lo chiamo il fisico
da fair play lo chiamo Nel senso che non
è un fisico arrogante il mio sono un
metro e 76 con la rincorsa
e quindi ci sono anche persone che non
mi conoscono che giustamente Penseranno
che le sto prendendo in giro No io sono
stato giocatori pallavolo forte anche e
ho vissuto insomma in mezzo a tutti
questi giganti che spesso mi chiedevano
Ma come ti trovi tu con quel io dicevo
Guarda che l'unico normale sono io
perché io e rientro nella media sono gli
altri che probabilmente hanno dei
problemi Ma mmm volevo iniziare diciamo
questa cosa per portarvi all'inizio
della mia carriera
e io sono Salentino lo sapete sono di
Squinzano provincia di Lecce
e ha avuto un inizio molto particolare
intanto Ecco vi spiego la foto e questo
giocatore È un giocatore Russo di nanken
si chiama 2 metri e 16 questo anche per
farvi capire
in che mondo vissuto e vi dicevo io ho
iniziato a giocare a pallavolo a
Squinzano nel mio paese ho iniziato per
caso perché
mi piaceva giocare a calcio uno che
piace molto lo sport ne risentiva un
pochino quello che era il mio diciamo
rendimento scolastico Come si dice
Quindi i miei genitori mi hanno
vivamente chiesto di non toccare più la
palla coi piedi di smettere di pensare a
studiare un pochino c'era una squadra
Squinzano tanti anni fa di pallavolo che
era in serie B secondo me non lo so come
mai serie B sarebbe una serie A2 di
adesso E allora siccome mi piaceva lo
sport dovevo diminuire il mio impegno
diciamo nella nella parte
sportiva e quindi studiare un pochino si
allenavano tre volte la settimana ho
detto va bene vado mi piace vado ho
provato mi sono innamorato di questo
sport Mi sono innamorato ed ero anche
abbastanza come dire bravo cioè ero
portato per fare questo sport
E allora da quando ho visto che riuscivo
a fare ho cominciato chiaramente a fare
i miei pensieri miei sogni di arrivare
in nazionale Comunque tutte le mie cose
ma c'è stato una frase che mi ha
accompagnato lungo tutto il percorso
da giocatore che era questa
ha dei Georgie bravo ma se avesse 5 cm
in più potrebbe giocare in questo caso
in serie B alla spesa allora io questa
frase l'ho sentita continuamente Ah
Bravo bravo avesse 5 cm potrebbe giocare
in due e quindi diciamo io facevo i miei
passi Ma bravo ma avessi 5 cm più
potrebbe giocare in A1 nella superlega
fatte i miei passi C'è voluto un po' di
tempo fino alla nazionale De Giorgi se
avesse quei 5 cm in più potrebbe essere
veramente un giocatore della nazionale
poi ci sono arrivato
Hanno smesso chiaramente di dirmelo
perché non c'era qualcos'altro in più ed
allenatore vi faccio vedere una
prospettiva
Ecco diciamo da allenatore non è che la
prospettiva non è cambiata quindi io ho
avuto questo
percorso e devo dire Benedetto quello
ostacolo perché mi ha spinto intanto a
capire una cosa che gli altri ci mettono
dei limiti Tutti ci guardano i difetti
che abbiamo cioè non ci aspettiamo che
qualcuno magari incontrare quelle
persone che di valorizzano ci sono ma
sono poche Quindi quando una persona ti
vede subito la Roma quello 5 cm manca
qualcosa ne manca questo qui E quindi
cosa ho cercato di fare io e pensare che
con i difetti
con i difetti si può arrivare
a vincere si può arrivare a fare delle
cose buone ho pensato di avere Ok 5 cm
non li posso prendere da nessuna parte
invece non è una cosa che a meno che vi
ricordate L'intrepido aveva quelle
scarpe da 7 cm che vendevano No quelle
cose lì ma posso mettere un plantare ma
non c'è da fare questa cosa loro ho
pensato Guardate cerco di vedere con la
qualità che ho con le qualità che ho se
posso equilibrare questa situazione Cioè
se posso trovare un modo ugualmente per
poter arrivare
agli successi che volevo al Nazionale o
giocare in Super League eccetera e
quindi mi sono concentrato su quello che
avevo
e soprattutto cercare di dire Va bene io
a muro sai Stai sotto rete sei piccolino
e fai un pochino fatica qui la squadra
perde qualcosa bene perdo non so tre
punti in questo fondamentale ne devo
guadagnare 4-5 negli altri fondamentali
e quindi diventare un palleggiatore io
ero palleggiatore molto bravo
tecnicamente un palleggiatore al di
sopra della media dal punto di vista
strategico un difensore per recuperare
qualche pallone in più Che perdevo
davanti ho cercato degli equilibri il
fatto che con questo ragazzo Direi che è
una finale di Coppa Italia nel 2001 lui
giocava a Parma io giocavo a Cuneo
finale giocata al Forum di Assago
10-12.000 persone un sacco di gente che
c'era e i miei compagni disgraziatamente
in un'azione mi hanno lasciato da solo a
murare un attacco di questo qua Cioè io
non so perché stavo da solo poi potete
immaginare io mi sono arrampicato la
rete alta 2,43 cioè con queste manine a
guadagnare 5 cm però volevo solo diciamo
fare non è che avevo delle grossi grandi
ambizioni diciamo ne voleva loro lui è
stato così bravo che mi ha colpito le
mani Cioè dico così perché io ho preso
il muro ho fatto un muro da solo a uno
di 2 metri e 16 punto chiaramente un
momento di silenzio poi tutto il forum
in piedi perché era una cosa eccezionale
io non l'ho fatto pesare neanche perché
ho fatto solo due giri di campo così ehm
l'ha fatto lui
[Musica]
Era solo per non far notare la cosa e
lui potete immaginare un giocatore di
quel livello che è murato da me con le
manine così se n'è tornato dietro
chiaramente depresso guardato male anche
dai compagni quindi però la cosa bella è
stata l'azione dopo Perché l'azione dopo
gli hanno ridato la palla io con
arroganza sono andato a murare di nuovo
dalla parte sua Ti giuro mi ha fatto un
punto attirato non so un altro io non
l'ho neanche sentito dove è passato la
palla allora lui poi si è avvicinato
vicino alla rete mi ha fatto uh uh alla
Russia io ho detto Bravo complimenti hai
fatto una cosa difficilissima non l'ha
fatta nessuno qui nel nella vita quindi
Eh questo diciamo
quell'esperienza con con dinieghi vi
voglio portare su un'altra parte ehm la
la maglia azzurra voi lo sapete che per
me questa
la marinatura è un qualcosa che è stato
sempre di grande di superiore pensate
che la prima convocazione a livello di
gioia di di potenza di cose e io la
paragono ai Mondiali che abbiamo vinto
Cioè hai avuto le stesse cose perché per
me era un desiderio una cosa incredibile
pensare di di
indossare questa maglia che dà
un'energia un orgoglio incredibile e
abbiamo fatto anche poi con quella
Nazionale come sapete un grande percorso
però vi voglio raccontare solo una cosa
della maglia azzurra Io ho smesso di
giocare a 41 anni eh
numero dei 5 esce abbastanza spesso e ho
smesso di giocare a 41 anni
con l'ultima partita giocata in
nazionale
ma non per una partita di addio Sai
quelle che si organizzano per dare
l'addio ma una partita di un mondiale e
questo è stato un motivo di grande
orgoglio Ma è nato mi ricordo benissimo
da
quando mi hanno consegnato il premio
alla carriera a 32 anni Allora voi
dovete sapere una cosa nello sport se
consegnano un premio alla carriera a un
giocatore non è un buon senso non è
cioè il premio alla carriera è uno
sportivo mentre ancora è in attività
suona da largo ai giovani diciamo Ecco
quello che hai fatto va bene eccetera
quindi quando mi hanno dato questo
premio mi hanno fatto riflettere allora
Pensavo dico ma quale sarà la mia nuova
forma mi piacerebbe diventare allenatore
cosa però mi piacerebbe ancora lo voglio
giocare giocare l'ultima perché un
atleta dovrebbe finire con l'ultima
partita nazionale Cioè significa che
finisce al massimo della tua attività
della tua forza eccetera e questo era un
sogno era un sogno però ho detto anche
qui Mettiamoci verso Se questo è
l'obiettivo sarà difficile perché ci
sono cambi generazionali possono
capitare infortuni Dipende dove sei dove
ho detto ok e mi sono messo con il
pensiero
di migliorare ogni giorno ogni giorno
ogni stagione
mi serviva dovevo sentirmi migliorato in
qualcosa che fosse tecnico fisico Quindi
avevo l'obiettivo di fare passi avanti
di mantenermi fisicamente bene di
gestirmi in un certo modo poi sarà stata
diciamo fortuna sarà stata quello che è
ma il treno è passato e io ero in
stazione perché ero proprio lì a
prenderlo non ho cioè non ho un giorno
non ho mollato con quell'idea di finire
la mia carriera del giocatore con la
maglia Nazionale si è avverato questo
questo coso Ma c'è stata una grande
preparazione insistenza diciamo da
questo punto di vista
Voi direte cosa c'entra questa cosa
perché io sono diventato allenatore Poi
sono diventato allenatore
ho preso questa nuova forma credevi
passare da giocatore allenatore è un
passaggio di quelli Tosti diciamo non
c'entra niente Cioè tu sei il giocatore
pensi di aver fatto e di avere dei bonus
ma non ce li hai deve ripartire da capo
devi ripartire da nuove conoscenze da
noi vedete da essere gestito devi
gestire devi preparare devi conoscere
eccetera quindi riparti da zero Anzi da
sotto zero perché se Guardate quella
temperatura Questa è stata una delle mie
esperienze da allenatore diciamo più
importanti e più estreme
un Salentino in Siberia ho allenato una
squadra i nuovi Rangone è una città
cittadina siberiana
e a 60 km dal circolo polare artico
Beh più estremo di così e poi Il
Salentino che va in questi posti
è sempre il titolo di un film di Checco
Zalone un Salentino sarebbe male dargli
un'idea di questo tipo però è stata
un'esperienza importante anche di
adattamento di capacità una scuola di
resilienza di resistenza Il Salentino in
Siberia c'ha 60 gradi di differenza
questa cosa qui perché quando mi
chiedono ma tu come hai fatto a
resistere a questa cosa qui Allora
intanto ogni che adattamento il
cambiamento
e alcune cose le accetti se hai uno
scopo se c'hai un obiettivo
resisti più facilmente e cambiati adatti
più facilmente Questo è poco ma è sicuro
l'altra cosa gli ho detto sono riuscito
a resistere perché ho portato i tre
pilastri di un Salentino
insostituibili per affrontare qualsiasi
sfida
olio d'oliva
friselle e il caffè io ho portato queste
tre cose
e con queste Ho sconfitto diciamo
la nostalgia il sole non lo potevo
portare però mi sono portato la vitamina
D che comunque poteva servire perché
anche quella era una cosa che che
mancava velocemente passo a questo che
Questo è un fotomontaggio eh non è una
foto reale la chiamata perché io poi
tutta l'esperienza dell'allenatore sono
arrivato l'anno scorso ad essere
chiamato a fare l'allenatore della
Nazionale questa Nazionale poi vi potete
immaginare che grande soddisfazione
perché per uno che ha fatto tutto il
percorso del giocatore poter poi
allenare la propria nazionale è una cosa
di un grande Orgoglio e onore Lì c'è il
presidente non fotomontaggio e ho
scritto la chiamata perché è stata una
chiamata ma anche perché il nostro ruolo
da allenatore io lo vedo veramente come
dei devi sentire la vocazione come dei
missionari sai fare il nostro mestiere
devi avere la vocazione perché sennò
ti mettono continuamente alla prova però
mi ha chiamato Io sono andato il 5
luglio e qui il 5 torno un'altra volta
mi hanno dato diciamo ehm l'ok per
allenare Però c'era solo un problema
perché le olimpiadi Erano state spostate
di un anno per il problema del Copy
quindi dal 20 sono entrate nel 2021 che
gli anni poi che io dovevo iniziare il
mio percorso diciamo il quadriennio
Olimpico quindi ho dovuto aspettare
la fine delle Olimpiadi perché c'era un
altro allenatore e altri giocatori che
si erano conquistati questa possibilità
di farlo e quindi era corretto diciamo
aspettare quindi ho dovuto aspettare e
sono entrato subito dopo le olimpiadi
con 20 giorni di tempo per preparare un
europeo
non è una situazione molto comoda Io ho
fatto un cambio generazionale
fortissimo otto esordienti ragazzi 19 20
21 anni la squadra più giovane
dell'europeo su una media di 23 anni due
più tre cinque anche qui e
ed è stata una scelta che era
indipendente dal risultato delle
Olimpiadi e non c'entrava niente Era
proprio un mio percorso che volevo
iniziare certo non era molto
consigliabile avendo 20 giorni di tempo
però
è una cosa che ho voluto fare perché ci
ho creduto fermamente gli ho dato una
grande fiducia a questo percorso
20 giorni sono stati sei allenamenti e
due amichevoli
Con questi sei allenamenti e due
amichevoli noi ci siamo presentati al al
mondiale preparati e mondiale Scusate
l'europeo preparando queste europee Poi
molti di voi sapranno un pochino Come è
andato no poi l'europeo di questi
ragazzi i miei
Però io vi voglio raccontare solo di
un'esperienza
Se solo avessimo avuto più esperienza
qui ritornando sempre al discorso dei
difetti che si guardano i difetti le
cose che mancano che come se non si
possa arrivare ugualmente a vincere
cercando una nuova forma Giusti
equilibri quando siamo arrivati alle
semifinali contro la Serbia
incominciava a girare questa voce
soprattutto partita dai giornalisti poi
internet Sì ma noi siamo Sì una squadra
però non abbiamo esperienza
tutti ragazzi la squadra più giovane
dell'europeo 8 esordienti 23 anni
giochiamo contro la Serbia la Serbia
dalla gente che ha fatto finali
olimpiche hanno vinto europei mondiali
Adesso sai sono le partite che contano
dentro fuori non c'è spengo e girava
questa cosa della mancanza
dell'esperienza Allora io ho dovuto come
dire mettere puntare un pochino i piedi
e parlare coi ragazzi perché
incominciavano anche loro a entrare
questa cosa che mi sembrava quasi già
prepararsi un alibi se le cose fossero
andate male
cioè guardare come stavano facendo e
come fanno spesso le persone da fuori le
cose che ti mancano le cose che non hai
Allora L'esperienza è importantissima
Io non dico che l'esperienza non sia
importante ma in quel contesto
non ce la poteva dare nessuno cioè noi
giocavamo abbiamo giocato i quarti di
finale dopo un giorno Dovevamo giocare
le semifinali non è che in un giorno
dove andavo a prendere questa esperienza
quindi stiamo parlando di qualcosa che
ci limitava nel pensiero già
invece di pensare a quello che avevamo
una cosa che non potevamo sostituire noi
avevamo che stavamo giocando bene a
pallavolo
che non è poco
allora gli ho detto ragazzi Invece di
pensare a quello che non abbiamo
pensiamo a mettere quello che abbiamo
cerchiamo bene a pallavolo
l'esperienza non la Sostituisci
l'esperienza la puoi compensare e come
la compensi con il gioco se giochi
meglio degli altri esperienze
un'esperienza un'esperienza degli altri
con l'aiuto la squadra
entra un compagno da una mano un pallone
in più un pallone in più dell'altro la
compensi
e quindi cercare di spostare
l'attenzione su quello che abbiamo non
su quello che non abbiamo che
soprattutto come era per i centimetri
non la puoi avere è inutile che stai lì
a parlare di quella cosa e poi sapete
come è andata no com'è andata
[Musica]
questi ragazzi hanno giocato tra l'altro
una finale contro la Slovenia che era
un'altra di quelle squadre esperte con
una grande esperienza perché abbiamo
vinto una finale 3 a 2 forse la partita
più complicata sempre sotto sono stati
sempre compatti non si sono mai disuniti
ci sono aiutati a destra e sinistra e
quindi il valore diciamo di quello che
hanno fatto questi ragazzi è veramente
importante io adesso per chiudere
diciamo
questo nostro incontro di racconto vi
voglio dire solo una cosa che la
responsabilità la motivazione come noi
selezioniamo davanti a delle situazioni
e
l'idea che voglio lasciarvi è in che
modo affrontiamo la situazione Cioè
guardiamo sempre quello che ci manca
anche a me dicevano che non c'erano
giovani
per poter fare una nazionale Quando ho
iniziato a prendere no Sì ma non ce
l'abbiamo I giovani non è vero perché
dipende cosa guardi cosa vuoi devi
guardare le potenzialità poi creare un
contesto coerente dove metterli fargli
esprimere e quindi guardiamo sempre
quello che non che non abbiamo o
cerchiamo di trovare delle forme con le
qualità che abbiamo per raggiungere
ugualmente chiaro che il processo che
c'è scritto su questa slide del lavoro
per arrivare perché non è teoria questo
qui poi c'è la parte tutta pratica
arrivare a usare il difetto come uno
stimolo per arrivare alla perfezione
diciamo così e l'allenamento
l'applicazione che si fa e lì c'è una
frase che mi piace molto che quella di
allenare quello che non mi piace sapete
perché Perché bisogna uscire dalla zona
comfort
perché se stiamo sempre nella zona
comfort è difficile fare dei passi in
avanti allenare quello che non mi piace
e soprattutto
Ricordatevi che il miglioramento non ha
età Grazie
[Applauso]